- Welcome back everybody.
Next week marks the start of Passover
the major Jewish holiday
that celebrates freedom,
after hundreds of years of enslavement.
It's coming at a time when
there's serious concern,
within the Jewish community
between antisemitic comments,
from high profile figures and
the rise in vicious attacks.
So many are living in fear,
which is in just a shame.
My next guest is a young TikTok star,
whose dance moves helped her rack up,
over 12 million followers on social media.
Now she's actually using
her global platform,
to spread awareness and
combat antisemitism.
We call that a rad human.
(cheerful music)
Everybody, please welcome Montana Tucker.
(crowd cheers)
- Hi, thank you for having me.
- You're welcome.
You have the greatest
name ever, by the way.
- Thank you so much, it is
my birth name, I promise.
- Montana Tucker is the coolest name ever.
- Thank you, thanks.
- I know to mama she's here with us today,
but that's a cool name.
So how did I have to ask,
how did you become an advocate
for the Jewish community?
- Yes, so I started off making,
these really happy fun dance videos
and with the recent rise in anti-Semitism,
I knew that I wanted
to do something bigger
and deeper with my platform.
And I am a proud Jewish woman.
Both of my grandparents
are Holocaust survivors.
- [Kelly] Wow.
(crowd applauds)
- Thank you, thank you.
And I always heard the
stories my whole life.
My grandparents used to
speak at all their schools
and all the schools, and it
was always important for them,
education, education.
So my Zaide grandfather,
he passed away three and a half years ago,
but he used to wear a pin
all the time that said,
never forget, never again, I'm a survivor.
So I knew that now this is my turn,
this is my turn to make sure
that people never forget.
- Absolutely, what a beautiful legacy,
to keep reminding everyone.
So what was the response when
you started kind of shifting?
- So when I first posted
just a lighthearted,
photo of my grandparents, the
comments were so shocking.
I don't even want to repeat
some of them on live TV,
but a lot of them were,
I shared that my grandparents
were Holocaust survivors
and that I was Jewish.
And people said, oh of
course you're Jewish
and making everything about yourself
or the Holocaust never existed.
I mean, how could people say
the Holocaust never existed?
- Well, some people still think
the planet earth is flat so.
- It's mind boggling to me.
- Keep walking.
- [Montana] Keep walking,
where are you gonna go?
- Find the end.
- Seriously.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so I knew that, you know,
I had this opportunity now to educate.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Montana] And over 60, there's a survey,
that said over 60% of millennials,
didn't know that over 6 million Jews,
were killed in the Holocaust.
- How do they not learn that in school?
I remember learning that in school alone.
- Well, apparently not
all states in the US,
require Holocaust education.
- Wow.
- [Montana] Yeah.
- I'm so blessed, I was at a school,
that literally took us to Dachau,
I think is how you pronounce it.
Yeah and it was, I encourage every school,
to do every kind of, we were, you know,
not a rich city where I'm from,
and we had to like raise money to go,
but when we went overseas,
it makes the most impact to a child,
to see something like
that and go, wait, what?
Like this happened?
And you walk through everything.
It moves you in such a different way.
And I think people that
have never experienced that,
sometimes people can have a hard time,
even believing it was real, right?
Because it's so horrfic.
- That's why like,
people need to see this,
people need to experience it.
- [Kelly] That's why
the pin was important,
that tour Grandfather wore, yeah.
- And even if you don't
have the opportunity,
to go to a camp which I
hope that everyone can,
but if you don't have.
- Even Googling at this point,
like whenever I was young
they didn't have like,
don't have the option,
I'm a lot older than you.
There wasn't the option of like,
now you can literally get
online and see so much
and there's so much information out there.
- And unfortunately there's
still so much doubt.
- [Kelly] And so much misinformation.
- Yeah.
- That is a problem as well.
Well, you were inspired
to take a trip to Poland.
So tell us about that trip.
- Yes, so there's another study that says,
over 90% of the Jews
in Poland were killed,
during World War II.
My grandma is a survivor of Auschwitz,
which was a camp in Poland.
- Yeah.
- And so I knew that I
always wanted to go there.
My mom and I talked about
going there for years,
because again hearing my
grandparents' stories,
my whole life but never really
had the opportunity to go.
And I had a good friend, Israel Shater,
who was like you know what,
we're gonna have you go.
And I knew it was gonna be the absolute,
hardest experience in my life.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But the most important
and I knew it would make
my grandparents so proud.
- Yeah, what a cool thing to
do with your platform, man.
That's so cool.
- Thank you.
- Well, and you turn that trip
into a documentary, right?
That's what we're talking about.
- Yes, a docu-series called
"How to Never Forget".
We made it solely for social media.
So it's available on all of
my social media platforms.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you know, yes, this
story is my story, right?
It's about my grandparents,
it's about my ancestors, my
people, the Jewish people.
But I knew if I brought
all of my followers
and also millions of people,
that may not follow me along with me.
- Yeah.
- This would now become their story also.
And hopefully all together
we can combat anti-Semitism
and all forms of hate.
- Yeah, absolutely, information is key.
(crowd applauds)
And so Montana you told
us about your trip,
with your mom when you went to Poland.
So it's part of the documentary, right?
- Yes, so this clip that
you're about to see,
it is my mom and I standing in Auschwitz,
which is the camp that my
grandma is a survivor of.
We stand on tracks where
over a million Jews,
were taken millions of people,
but over a million Jews
were taken to their death.
We stand, it's a very,
very emotional piece.
We stand where my mother,
I'm sorry my grandmother
last saw her mother.
And you're gonna see it in this next clip.
It's very emotional.
- All right, well let's
take a look everybody.
- I think that your great grandma knew,
she was going to be marched to her death.
- [Montana] My mom tells
me the horrific story,
of my 13 year old grandma and her mother,
being put in the line for death,
while her sister was
put in the other line,
right here on these tracks.
My grandma tried to stay with her mom,
but her mom had told her,
whatever happens you stay
with your older sister.
- That saved her life.
- [Montana] The line she left,
went right to the gas chambers.
I feel like I would've ran
to the other line and said,
"take me with you".
I wouldn't have been
able to not go with you.
- Montana's mama Michelle's
actually in the audience,
with us today, hi Michelle.
- Hi Kelly.
- [Kelly] Thank you for joining us.
- Thank you for having me.
- So how did you feel
when you were sharing,
that story with Montana?
- I envisioned myself as my grandmother
and Montana as my mother,
and my mother was only 13.
And Mangala split them
up and separated them.
And that was the last place,
that my mother saw her mother get beaten
and dragged to the gas chambers.
And I looked at Montana and I said,
no one's ever gonna separate us.
And she put her arm around on me.
We walked arm in arm where
my mother had to walk alone
and Montana, I got to
walk with my daughter
and she got to walk with her mother.
And we walked into Auschwitz together,
where my mother had to walk alone.
- Wow, I'm just gonna need a minute.
- Every time.
- Humans can be, wow.
I mean, we can do beautiful
things, but we can be horrific.
What connections do you
feel between the Holocaust
and modern day antisemitism?
What do you feel the connections are?
- Unfortunately, I feel there
are way too many connections.
I visited a camp called Belzec,
which is a death camp in Poland.
Over 500,000 people were murdered there,
there were only two
survivors from this camp
and they had a small museum there.
I went into this museum
and there was this picture
that really stood with me.
It was a picture of all these Nazis,
laughing and making fun of
a Jewish man with his beard.
And I saw that picture
and that picture really resonated with me,
because we see photos
like that all the time,
on social media now all
the time, scrolling past,
you see these types of photos.
- It's almost like you're desensitized.
- Exactly.
- Yeah.
- And those photos were sent as postcards,
back to their family being
like, look what I'm doing.
Which is bizarre, but that's again,
what's happening nowadays, right?
- [Kelly] Wow.
- With the videos you see surfacing,
with the photos, you see surfacing.
So people say, "oh the Holocaust
can never happen again",
right, this could never happen again.
How could we allow something
like this to happen again?
But unfortunately, if we don't
come together as a community,
of all religions, races, ethnicities,
if we don't come together
and combat anti-Semitism,
and all forms of hate,
it's gonna happen again.
It means unfortunately starting to happen.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So that's why this is so important.
- Absolutely.
(crowd applauds)
Well there's a few simple
things that you can do,
right now to help spread
awareness and combat hate.
The foundation to combat anti-Semitism,
is launching a new campaign
called Stand Up to Jewish Hate.
They've shared some facts with us,
that are pretty staggering
that you touched on slightly.
You've probably noticed
that there's a blue square,
appearing on your screen right now.
It's taking up 2.4% of the screen,
which actually represents
the entire Jewish population,
in the US, but Jewish
people are victims of 55%,
of all religious hate
crimes in the country,
which is horrific.
All of it is horrific, but
like such a small percentage,
like it's incredible.
So you can help raise awareness
by sharing that blue
square emoji in your phone,
on all social media
platforms to stand up to hate
and intolerance and just
keep reminding people,
to never forget.
So thank you so much for
sharing your story with us.
- [Montana] Thank you so much.
- It's not easy to like,
share this kind of story,
with everybody and walk around with that,
especially with people attacking you,
as well as supporting you.
So thank you for doing that.
- Thank you, thank you so much.
- For more of Montana,
you can follow her on social media,
y'all please do.
And also, please check out
her powerful documentary,
"How to Never Forget" on YouTube.
It's only 23 minutes long, so
I encourage everyone to watch.
It's just 23 minutes.
We'll be right back.